we begin with a very serious question
this isn't a joke
who is in charge at 1600 pennsylvania
avenue
look at this trafalgar that's robert
kahale and convention of
states poll one of the most accurate
pollsters in the country
a majority of the american people
believe that it is definitely not
joseph biden a whopping 57 percent
think that joe is not fully executing
the duties
of the office of president in other
words joe's not making the decisions
he's not in charge
i know at times on this program i have
joked about this but honestly
starting tonight this stops that stops
joke this is not a joking matter america
has a president that is now
obviously cognitively compromised
and not only the country sees it our
enemies see it
and this cannot be good for anyone
according to this poll look at these
numbers 58
of independents they see it even 32
percent of democrats
understand joe's not really the one in
charge that's right
a third of voters joe's own party
believe
joe's not capable of executing his
duties in the office of president
and of course they see what we all see
and that is
somebody that is weak and frail and a
cognitive mess
and a shell of his former self and it
only appears to be getting worse the
main question now
okay if he's not in charge and the polls
show that
most people don't think he is who is in
charge
who knew about joe's condition and what
did they know and when did they know it
over the weekend more struggles as biden
pulled out
two note cards in an unsuccessful
attempt to answer a pretty
simple basic fundamental question
this is like a softball you just knock
it right out of the park not joe he's
got to refer to the cards take a look
with the most recent hack by the
russians
would you say that this this means we're
not sure it's the russians
okay i got a brief on
as i was on the plane that's why it was
late getting off the plane
i'll be in better shape to talk to you
about it um
i'll tell you what they sent me okay
uh that uh
the idea first of all we're not sure who
it is for sure
number one and what i did i directed the
full resources of
the government to assist in a response
if we determine
that wasn't a hard question that didn't
need notes every hostile actor
every hostile regime in the world
they're studying him
every day and they're also becoming more
emboldened
every day look at this report chinese
state media
they're now publicly boasting about a
three-part plan to invade taiwan
in case you don't know america's top
ally in the region
in a long belligerent speech china's
well hostile actor
dictator xi actually said that
he is committed to the hostile takeover
of taiwan
also vowing at any country that stands
in china's way will quote
have their heads bashed bloody against
the great wall of steel
forged by over 1.4 billion chinese
people
now keep in mind china is now also the
media is ignoring this they have teamed
up with russia
and they're now supplying the muellers
in iran with dangerous weapons that
they're using in their proxy wars
all over the middle east now european
leaders they're voicing grave concerns
over
iran's nuclear program as the country
will now
soon again begin to produce enriched
uranium
and a massive violation of obama's
previous
and precious nuclear deal you know
billions of dollars
cargo planes of cash and other currency
no word on how biden plans to respond to
any of these situations just like it
appears
there appears to be a plan of action
against the kremlin
what's joe going to do after yet another
likely russian-based cyber attack
up to 1500 businesses were targeted this
time
the republican national committee
allegedly breached
so another serious question tonight joe
what are you going to do or maybe the
question doesn't go to joe
whoever is actually making decisions at
1600 pennsylvania avenue
what are you planning to do maybe you'll
divulge who you are publicly
and of course no one in the media mob is
going to hold biden accountable
ever ask a tough question just like no
one on fake news cnn
three broadcast channels msdnc
new york times washington post they
won't dare ask
questions about the mental capabilities
or lack thereof of their dear leader
just like they denied riots for riots
just like they protected
candidate joe biden and his basement
bunker now president joe
and remember these were the same idiots
who were the biggest proponents of all
they wanted to talk about was
oh the 25th amendment and whether or not
donald trump will get a cognitive test
all throughout the trump presidency in
fact it wasn't that long ago
that the armchair psychologist on the
left and in the media had no problem
diagnosing the president of the united
states and demanding his removal from
office for a variety of issues you might
recall
let's go as warner wolf said to the
videotape
rosenstein discussed recruiting cabinet
members
to invoke the 25th amendment to the u.s
constitution to remove mr trump from
office for being unfit people close to
him during the campaign
told me had early stages of dementia now
listen you can get mad at me if you want
to you can say that's not okay to say
but
it is okay to say he is unfit
invoke the 25th amendment this new york
times article basically showed us
how trump is not only in the early
stages of dementia
but he is in cognitive decline watching
this president from here i discussed the
25th amendment
at the end of the first month of the
trump presidency join the senate
democratic leader in calling on the vice
president
to remove this president by immediately
invoking the 25th
amendment he is unfit and he should step
aside
and it may take a 25th amendment to get
him to step aside
if we applied those standards to joe
we'd be invoking the 25th amendment and
asking him to step aside
now despite biden's obvious everyday
cognitive struggles
the media mob is suddenly unconcerned
with the mental capabilities of the
president of the united states
they're also totally unbothered by the
corrupt biden family syndicate
and yet another explosive report i can't
wait for a book to come out miranda
devine
texts from hunter's laptop from hell
show the president's son complaining
that he hunter
had to pay for quote everything for the
this entire family for 30 years
including daddy apparently while vice
president
other documents revealing that hunter
purportedly paying
for his father's cell phone bill phone
bill other household expenses
now why on earth would hunter we know at
the time a struggling crack addict and
prostitution addict apparently
uh why would he be paying his prominent
father's bills when he's wealthy
it's almost as if the big guy was just
taking his cut of the pie hey sean
hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else